[Música]
tem que ser um atleta de alta competição
ser um atleta de alta competição posso
dizer que não é nada fácil em portugal
com alguns pensavam em termos o futebol
eo resto é em cima da hora indica que é
uma das modalidades que vem desde o
início já que os contemporâneos 25 que
se mantenha até hoje em dia têm três
disciplinas o floresta a espada e sabre
eu faço a mais rápida é a mais técnica é
mais inteligente sofreu hoje em dia
treinou em frança onde trabalho e
representa 11 apresentou tamanho e
situação portuguesa e que sempre consigo
fazer o trabalho e continuar trabalhando
muito diversificadas e completas precisa
e ganha bastante maturidade posso dizer
com 16 anos já morava fora ou então eu
ia sozinho para a copa do mundo
as preparações as preparações que nós
temos
enquanto atleta o focus e treinamento
ltda
tudo isso tem a ver com a minha bela em
portugal
poucas condições as verbas são muito
poucas
nós temos muita qualidade mas disse não
chega hoje em dia fazemos de tudo somos
um país a conseguir estar na frente
tempos a tempos
por exemplo podemos ver aqui estou aqui
dificuldade mesmo assim conseguiu ganhar
um grande atleta
o o desporto a nível geral em portugal
precisa
sempre gostei de paixão que a paixão que
faz com que as pessoas ficam e se
entregam à dentro do esporte
hoje estou em paris
podemos ver aqui isto são as imagens de
ontem que vai consagrar vamos ter saído
na frança e aqui podemos ver aonde não
estamos entrosados como com os nossos
atletas e são coisas muito importantes
para o futuro tanto de uma criança como
pra mim ou por qualquer um de vocês a
nível social ou profissional
este valor que são ganhos desde muito
cedo são coisas que nos fazem em
ferimentos
posso dizer que a nível profissional foi
muito importante pra mim a parte da alta
competição o que me ensinou desde muito
cedo
hoje em dia estou muito agradecido e faz
parte está nas minhas performances a
nível internacional por conta da alta
competição é uma espécie de super homem
tem dois braços grave a idosa não é
muito fácil uma vivência de todas as
viagens que eu tive por todo o mundo a
alguém
agora vamos dizer que daqui a dez anos
acho que não vai viajar um terço do que
já fez grandes vantagens em ser uma
conta da alta competição
bush se cristiano ronaldo grima ano traz
muitos milhões mas trouxe uma outra
parte muito boa e acho que qualquer
pessoa a dispensarem por o seu filho no
futebol o em alguma coisa deve pensar
que o desporto dá muito em portugal
temos muita qualidade e acho que el nós
temos que pensar em tentar desenvolver
eu acho que há uma das funções que eu
trago aqui por causa da minha vivência
tanto no campeonato português com um
francês e nomeadamente uma proposta
quando era júnior durante dois anos
consecutivos pode sair da princesa anne
e que é um sistema que funciona muito
bem
ou seja o sistema universitário a
francesa descobriu o sistema
universitário americano el a grande base
do esforço americano importante cano
hoje em dia temos grandes atletas que
passaram como shaquille o'neil michael
jordan
james blake do tênis ou o gramado
molhado michael phelps a quantidade de
população que temos no estado somente
comprava a portuguesa da nossa 10
milhões para 320 e 18 e normalmente
conseguimos em todos os jogos olímpicos
24 dálias mais ou menos uma a duas
medalhas o que é impressionante a
qualidade dos cuidados de serviço à
população que nós temos
já o estado 121 medalhas em 318 milhões
não vai nem não é só qualidade e está um
sistema em que o atleta é basicamente
não tem que fazer nada pra mim treinar
desde o colegial a qual o livro inicia
depois comparam com os lançamentos que é
exatamente o
ô ô ô ô sistema universitário
nesse sistema universitário o atleta tem
um dia a via em dois ou três treinos e
aí é tudo feito em favor do dos treinos
do do atleta
temos a equipe pois as condições çom
seguintes temas ou seja tem tudo pago à
alimentação está havia viagem porto novo
todos os estados unidos é tudo incluído
tem treinadores preparadores físicos
treinos técnico-táticos basicamente
assente não tem nem fazer grande coisa
mas com qualidade já é que já já tom eu
soube sair e aí a pressão dos resultados
agora nós temos esta convidada seria se
nós fossemos os estados unidos ou se
tivermos a dimensão e as condições que o
estado está obrigado
[Aplausos]